theoretically a bunch of people that
said good morning to you that has not
happened to me yet because it is 5:00 in
the morning and I have to get on a plane
or as a guy that whole time I was
talking he's very quiet and you know
John that planes have a kind of but
whole majority the exhaust on a plane
comes out through the engines but there
is also a thing called the auxiliary
power unit which powers all of the
electronics on the plane like everything
from the crackling speakers to the
hydraulics to the vacuum powered poop
pump thingy and it vents out its exhaust
through a port that is called in my head
the plainest I was the punchline that's
why I told the whole story yep it's all
true though what century you know the
fish don't fart this is not sound that
weird but it's actually really weird or
some fish that use gas internally as
ballast most of them burp that up when
they need to get rid of some air but
some of them do have a come out the
other end but as far as like bacterial
gas produced in the gut of fish doesn't
come out of them it is produced though
because they have the same kind of gas
producing organisms in their gut that we
do it is a mystery where that gas goes
the weird thing for us to not know in
addition to being exhausted also
bursting with excitement internally
super that's quite a dance song really
just uh quite happy that at least 55% of
the Supreme Court the United States is
not crazy it's nice to see that Canadian
currencies made a bit of a comeback and
the only difference between it and
American currency now apparently is that
Canadians realize that 30 bucks in 29.95
or the same freakin thing yeah and
whenever you're going to Portland
everybody always says don't forget you
we been dropped off at a loading dock I
don't know what I'm doing or what I
should do now I think I just met someone
who's even more tired than me it's Devon
Murray there we go
how are you doing not too bad a little
bit worse
where with all the flying bush plant
again that is a terrible thing to say
but I keep expecting in the light
something on fire
tell me the story that you just told me
I just leave my microwave up the other
day I was at upstairs and all of a
sudden having a shower I come back
downstairs there's smoke all over hey
was only a brand-new microwave so first
time being used I should have watched it
doesn't sound like it was your fault oh
no of course wasn't okay what's still
house like at Sheamus
ah so it turns out that the castle is
even a diaries just breaks out into song
pretty frequently so many people are
never new and poor I'm about to go on
stage with lauren fairweather wearing my
worn a fair-weather shirt insert crowd
screaming now that's why I'm having to
get up early in the morning to do this
kind of stuff because that is better
than any amount of sleep possible John
but of course I was wrong when I said
that I won't see John on Tuesday I will
see Rosie on Tuesday I'm very tired I'm
going to go to bed yay pillow it so
happy about this bed